selena first time hosting you nervous
you got ants in your pants no i'm just
excited well you sure you sure you don't
have any ants in your pants no i'm good
selena gomez is gearing up to make her
saturday night live hosting debut but
not without taking a few jabs from the
cast first oh my goodness check out this
promo selena and musical guest post
malone who's also making his snl debut
get called out by aidy bryant and bo and
yang hi i'm selena gomez and i'm hosting
snl this week with post malone two pop
stars and two comedy actors huh i'm
actually also an actor and i'm not
really a pop star and i prefer drama
okay well i didn't know you were also a
bunch of divas rude and get this in the
next one post malone joins in on the
joke to tell selena a little secret
selena first time hosting you nervous
you got ants in your pants no i'm just
excited well you sure are you sure you
don't have any ants in your pants no i'm
good
maybe you should definitely check to see
if you actually have ants in your pants
wait guys is there something i should
know well yeah we spilled a bunch of
jelly in your pants and then we left
your pants outside for three days and
then i spilled my ant farm on your pants
sorry
one thing's for sure selena seemed so
ready to take over the snl stage she
shared this behind the scenes clip in
rehearsals showing off her freshly
manicured nails
[Music]
and while our girl sg has achieved a lot
in her decades-long career movies music
tv and more it's her first go at hosting
the sketch comedy series i'm excited and
after news of her snl debut was revealed
she shared her emotions on tick tock are
you okay no
no
no but yes i'm yes and no but this isn't
selena's first time taking the studio 8h
stage she previously appeared as the
musical guest in 2016 performing her
songs hands to myself and a good for you
same old love medleys
[Music]
but when it comes to hosting there's no
doubt selena is gonna bring the funny
i'm ready to do it you know i'm ready to
go to the next level she's been showing
off her comedy chops on tiktok
recreating famous scenes like this one
from shit's creek it's a write-off
that's a write-off yeah do you even know
what a write-off is uh yeah it's when
you buy something for your business and
the government pays you back for it oh
and who pays for it
nobody you write it off also the fact
that she works alongside comedy legends
martin short and steve martin on only
murders in the building doesn't hurt
either and these are candid photos i
took of our neighbors why are they all
selfies so i don't draw suspicion i'm
officially the third
amiga i should say yeah
[Music]